hello everyone and welcome to the
classical part of the alta box Norway
championship it's Magnus Magnus Carlsen
versus Vishwanathan Anand the two old
rivals brawling it out again and it's
really interesting the type of
tournament players playing a classical
game and then if that game is drawn then
they have a 15 or 20-minute rest and
then they immediately play an Armageddon
game keeping the same core color of
pieces but white will have ten minutes
and black will have seven minutes and
the white has to win the game so are
really an interesting format it's not
the first of its kind I've been told
that this form it has been used before
but it is the first time we're covering
this this type of event so without
further ado let's just check it out
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 with Knight to f6 c4 with East
six Knight to f3 and here we have d5
again we go into the Queens gambit
declined we have Knight to c3 and here D
captures on c4 with E for and Bishop to
b4 and I just pinning that knife
preparing to capture on e4 so Carlsen
goes Bishop to g5 pins denied and now we
have c5 and this game is now following
the same game Magnus Gosnell already
played against level origin in the
Greinke chest classic this year we
covered that game so you might have even
even seen it on this channel but subcat
first on c4 as in the game against level
our Nazi captors Knight captures and now
Bishop captures on c3 giving up the dark
square bishop for some nice ideas B
captures on c3 and now Queen to a5
attacking the bishop on g5 but also
threatening to win the c3 pawn with
check so in the game against Levin
Aragon that Magnus 1 if you remember
Bishop to d2 was played in this position
just getting the bishop arrow there as
its attacked and also guarding the the
c3 pawn but here even though cousin won
that game he decided not to repeat as of
course we she knows that game so he goes
for a different line Knight the b5 block
blocks the Queen's attack of the bishop
and also guards the c3 pawn so on of
course knows this line is well he just
continues playing rather quickly Knight
captures on e4 of course the knight is
no longer pin the Queen is not on d8
attacks again the bishop and g5 and here
Queen to d4 now again
c31 is defended twice and also the queen
is now eyeing the g-seven pawn so Anand
castles here a temporary peace sacrifice
on a cost and captures the night we have
Queen captures a need for a six now
keeping trying to kick away the night so
queen captors and c3 can be played and
here of course you cannot move it as you
don't want to allow this but here there
have a few moves that have been
attempted to your Bishop to d3 is one
such idea where of course the checkmate
was threatened but also there is also
the non line Bishop to e7 just attacking
the rook that goes into a force line
that is a capture some b5 and now Bishop
to b4 first kicking the Queen away from
the c3 pawn and after the Queen retreats
now Bishop to d3 threatening checkmate
you don't want to play something like g6
to all our Bishop captures rook so here
f5 you force the Queen to move Queen to
e2 and now II five and now black will
have a very nice game like I said it's
an online where you are not allowed to
capture the row kind of fate to do - of
course Queen captures and c3 would be
deadly you have to do something but you
will lose the rook and after you block
well Black has a lot of options but
basically you can even just trade Queens
and after King captures first even a
root cap for Sonny - after we move the
King King captures on f8 and at the end
of this very nice line you will be a
black will be up a piece and up three
points so a completely winning position
so these are the known moves here like
we mentioned after a six by Anand Bishop
d3 and Bishop to e7 but here no sir
there's 57 but here crossing castles and
it is a new move so as of move 13 we
have a completely new game we have a cap
for some b5 onon recaptures the piece
Bishop to d3 threatens checkmate and now
you could block it with the Jesus but
it's not you know something you want to
do you weaken the dark squares a bit too
much Queen h4 with some nasty ideas so
after B 3 will have
f5 by Anand and now Queen back to e2
just attacking the b5 pawn and here
nice to see six called on the prefers
development rather than trying to
unsuccessfully defend the BB pond with
Bishop back to d2 by Carlson and now
Queen back to c7 and now Magnus finally
recaptures the b point with bishop
characters on b5 and now f4 by anand
played rather quickly he's interested in
going what ee v e4 if possible and
pushing f3 so cross and you know stops
it with f3 that point is no longer going
anywhere and e 5 by Anand the point is
nicely protected by the Queen and by the
by the night we have rook F 2 e1
putting pressure on the e5 pawn and now
Bishop to d7 and here if you try
something like Bishop captures Bishop
captures and you want to go after the e5
pawn you get Queen captures on e5 rook
captures on e5 and then R ok da this was
an ins idea he wanted to give up a pawn
for some very nice active play with the
bishops of opposite color on the board
so it's a hard to save if having this
extra pawn could be actually turned into
something but cousin is not interested
first he pushes a for just nicely
cements that Bishop over there with King
to h8 getting the King away from this
diagonal as crossing the Sava light
square Bishop we look a to d1 now as the
the pawn is no longer an a2 so it's not
a target rook e8 e8
by Anand and now bush up to c1 with
ideas of coming all the way to a3 now to
assume this very nice diagonal
efore by Anand a pawn sacrifice that
should allow him some active play with F
captors and he for calls and accepts
nice the 5 now
and here Magnus just captures because
you don't want to allow f3 it seems like
a very ugly move to to allow black to
make so first cross and captures here
now you have to capture with the night
but it's very interesting if you include
DF to remove then yes you will ruin
White's pawn structure on the King side
somewhat but then after you recapture
it's hard to say if it's a plus for
black or not but it's it's well the
players Anand agrees that it's not
compensation enough for for two points
that and that Carson has extra even with
with the King being so so exposed in g1
so Anand first goes Knight captures here
and now we have looked to f1 just you
know putting that rook on the F file
which some may be possible roofless
the rocker f3 rock to h3 with nice the
c5 by Anand and now cross and said that
in the confessional that he was thinking
of going to c4 but then after he came
back to the board and he saw night to c5
he decided for a different move Bishop
to e3 it is the engines top
recommendations and cousin spent quite a
lot of time on this move so just pinning
that night as the rookies on f8 and then
next he can go either Queen to be five
or maybe some other move here on under
wins back the point we have rook
captures on e4 and now quinta b5 by
cross and but there was the option of
actually going Queen to h5 it's a very
nice line you're threatening to win
denied and denied the night can move the
rook is still on f8 but then you get
this line rookie five and then you have
to find the rook captures on f4 it's a
really a really nice line but it's hard
to say of course you cannot capture
because rook captures and f8 would be
checkmate you'd have to go route g8 and
then you get rook to f7 forcing a queen
trait and after captures captures you
would get this position Knight captures
on a4 c4 first preventing back from
recapturing and only then will you
continue playing this game the b7 point
is likely to fall and then you will try
to push your past C pawn so this was one
way to go about it cross and didn't go
for Queen h5 he went for Queen to be
five but now rook the e5 going into a
similar align the knight is not
protected and now Carson had the option
of going for this Bishop captures rook
captures and now just rook captures an
f4 with the the same idea
now if the queen is captured again rook
captures an F it would be checkmate and
if Queen captures then you would capture
on c5 and after h6 you do have you do
have to give your King some breathing
room even though the rook is defended
for the moment but your queen is unable
to recapture pawns so it probably goes
something like here and after Queen d4
again you would have this rockin Queen
endgame where white would be up upon
cross and doesn't like this he goes rook
D to e 1 and now we have looked a CA to
Ireland rook to e8 would be a terrible
mistake as Crossan just delivers
checkmate so you have to be careful
about something like this
so after Luke d2 e 1 we have looked a c8
by Anand and now comes Luke captures on
e5 cross and decides to trade everything
off Queen captures on e5 Bishop captures
on c5 with Queen
actors on c5 and now Carlson just
straight trade Queens rook captures on
c5 and now rook captures on f4 checkmate
is being threatened so we have eight six
by Annan and I looked back to f3 just
defending that c3 pawn King to g8 Anand
starts bringing his King into the game
now comes Luke to d3 we have looked a
five hoping to grab ba for pawn we have
looked at b7 going after the b7 point
here they trade pawns and now rook to e8
to not allowing crossing scheme to to
cross over the the second-ranked so
Carson has to do differently with h4 the
King might now go into the game via D
squares
King to h7 and now King to h2 we have
looked the d2 now and here rook to c7
now Carson is still controlling the
seventh rank and preparing to push the
c4 pawn king to g6 and here King to g3
cross and also stars bringing his King
into the game and now King to h5 with
rook the c5 with check King King doesn't
go back as this would allow white a lot
of a lot of squares so just g5 we have
King to h3 by crossing and now rook to
d3 check with King to sorry we have g3
blocking check and now rook to e3 just
holding everything intact and it's very
hard to decide what to do here if you
move the rook to start pushing your past
C pawn then at this point this sorry the
Jeep on is no longer pin so you will be
able to trade it here and you don't
really have a good way of continuing so
here a cross and just went into g2 but
now look back to d3
now we have grouped the c-4 now and here
rook to e3 and just waits to see what
crossing will do we have a trade here on
the G file and now King to h3 we have
route back to d3 now comes Luke to see
it and now finally
g4 with check King to g2 look to d2 with
check and now King to f1 and here look
the c2 and I'm just puts his room behind
a passed pawn as that's what you always
want to do and our cross and starts
pushing it so King to g5 Anand has to
bring his king as close as possible we
have a c5 and now comes King to f6
with c6 King to e7 nikons c7 and here
King to d6 and here we have roped the DA
check now Crossin will give a check here
or give up at this point but then he
will recapture the G for point we have
looked to d4 King to c6 and now we have
King to g1 with King to c5 and here
finally Carlsen recaptures here he's up
upon but this is a well known draw so it
was in this position that Magnus calls
an Englishman at annulment the two old
rivals the agreed to a draw as both both
of them are fully capable of playing
this out to a draw perfectly so that's
that's pretty much it and here's a bit
of a spoiler results wise if you don't
want to hear it just you know skip a few
minutes or a minute but all of the all
of the classical games have ended in a
draw and all of the games went into
Armageddon so here if you're interested
I will immediately show the Armageddon
game between Magnus cross and if an
attack on
so the first link in the description
below just click on it it will
immediately take you to the Armageddon
game between crossing around if you want
to see how they played it out did
unearned win with the black pieces was
he able to draw or maybe cousin one with
the white pieces having more time but
for you know he was forced to go for the
win
sure once again that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
think of a silly Cairo for contributed
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon well
like I said do check out the the
Armageddon game between Carson and Anand
if you if you if you want to see how the
encount encounter ended I think your and
I will see you soon
well very quickly